The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
mitopencourseware@osu.mit.edu.
AMY BANZAERT: I hope you're
getting excited about the trip.
So there are a few things that I
managed to skip over last time.
One is solar cookers.
It somehow got dropped
from my presentation
and they're a kind of
key part of cooking
that I want to talk about.
But at least most of you guys
have investigated a little bit
on your own.
And then we're also just talking
about the energy to boil water.
So in terms of solar cookers,
as Grupo Phoenix mentioned,
there are three types.
So there's the concentrator
or parabolic method,
where you have some sort
of parabolic collector
that's aiming the heat onto your
cooking cook stove, which is
then heating up the material.
You have the box method, which
is using a greenhouse method,
where you have a reflective
device reflecting
into the greenhouse.
And that's pretty much the
design that Grupo Phoenix uses.
I wouldn't call it a
hybrid, because the hybrid
has both that
greenhouse, but also uses
some parabolic features
to collect the energy.
And you can see that the cost--
you can imagine the cost of
these three devices shown
varies.
And so you can get very
inexpensive versions
of all of these--
but the parabolic is
definitely the hardest
to get super cheap--
and very expensive versions.
So I wanted to start
by just talking
about what you think
might be some pros
and cons of solar cookers.
AUDIENCE: Can I
ask you a question?
Is the material that they use--
what is it?
[INAUDIBLE] just sheet
metal or aluminum foil.
AMY BANZAERT: So sheet
metal is pretty--
yeah, it's hard to get a really
good reflection off of it.
So I think I've
seen some that are
basically mirrors, so that's,
I think, what that is.
This is a plastic that's
super shiny, that's
just laminated
onto the cardboard,
so a whole range from
expensive to non.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Is the concentrator-- what is
it concentrating it toward,
the box or toward--
AMY BANZAERT: No, so
this is an open pan.
So it's just concentrating
it on the pan.
So this is the difference--
the concentrator is just
shining a strong ray
of heat onto something.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Solar cookers
are very rarely electrical.
I've never seen--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] was having
a meter panel [INAUDIBLE] house
where you could
charge your cellphone
and you could also cook.
But then that would
have definitely-- we're
thinking about the panel
outside on the roof
collecting the rays,
collecting the solar energy,
transferring it into
electrical energy,
and getting it to solar
cooker [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: So
I think that would
be a really good estimation
exercise, to figure out
what it takes to make
a solar cooker that's
an electrical solar cooker.
Because do you remember how many
Watts a typical stove or oven
is?
AUDIENCE: A lot.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So a typical like burner
is 1,000 to 1,500 Watts.
A typical oven is 3,000 Watts.
So we're talking
really different scopes
in terms of what a
cellphone charger is
and what cooking
is, needs to be.
And so that's a high
barrier to entry.
So you need to look into
the viability of that.
OK, so can we make
a list of what
you think are the
bonuses of solar cookers,
and what are some
of the drawbacks?
Benjy.
AUDIENCE: It's free
after you buy it.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah,
so it's free energy.
AUDIENCE: Zero emissions.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A con is
that you might not
be able to have right
outside your home,
like that girl standing in a
river, which is probably not
outside her home.
AMY BANZAERT: So it
needs to be outside.
AUDIENCE: You have to
find a sunny location.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it's [INAUDIBLE]
weather dependent.
AMY BANZAERT: Seth.
AUDIENCE: Apart from the
concentrator cookers,
they can't fry food.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so your
cooking options are limited.
So yeah, you can absolutely
fry food with the concentrator,
but it can be hard
to get a low heat,
if you want a low heat
in a concentrator.
Carter.
AUDIENCE: Portability.
AMY BANZAERT: Portability, yeah,
so I'll put that in the middle.
Well, and there's a real--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
actually, portability
would be grow the
economy of scale.
Does that make sense?
You can move it around,
but only to a certain size.
AMY BANZAERT: Well,
but you can see here,
like this-- this is a highly
portable solar cooker.
That parabolic
generator actually
folds up into something
that's not much bigger--
it's significantly
smaller than this.
So that is super portable.
Whereas that concentrator
is a fixed location.
So some are portable,
some are not.
And then if they're portable,
that can be helpful,
but then it's limited by size.
So I think actually leaving it
in the middle is reasonable.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
scale or size [INAUDIBLE]
you're limited to certain
sizes [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
I don't if that is any more
true than it is for any stove.
AUDIENCE: Touche.
AMY BANZAERT: Any
other thoughts?
Yeah, Missy.
AUDIENCE: Well, obviously,
a lot of your emissions,
you have the benefit
of [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah,
so no emissions,
which yields better health.
AUDIENCE: There's [INAUDIBLE]
no preparation time.
You don't have to
collect the fuel.
AMY BANZAERT: No
fuel collection,
which sort of links to that
one, because it's either
time or money, generally.
Sid.
AUDIENCE: I guess a con would
be that if you're constantly
changing the angle, and you're
cooking for a long period
of time, [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: OK, yeah, Benjy.
AUDIENCE: For fires [INAUDIBLE].
So if someone were
to have [INAUDIBLE]..
I mean, you're not using any
energy anyway so [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah,
because people
do use their fires for
heating, for mosquito control,
for light, sometimes.
Yeah.
OK, super, so I think
that's a pretty good list.
To give you some
background, solar cookers
were invented in the mid 1700s.
So they've been around
for a really long time.
And I think that is
an indicator of how
this is a great
technology in some cases.
But isn't ever going to be
the killer app that solves
the world's cooking challenges.
Because one would think
if they've been around
since the 1700s
that the refinement
that takes it to
killer app would
have been developed already.
But the cons of it--
weather dependent,
it's time dependent,
you need to be in
a sunny location,
you need to be outside--
are all really huge.
So some of the challenges
with the concentrators
are the glare and
just how hot it is.
So it's kind of hard to
see because the quality
of the picture has gone down
going through the projector.
But this woman is
grimacing because it's
so bright that it's
actually hard to deal with,
and it's also very
hot where it is.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Dangerous.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So the concentrators in
particular are dangerous.
And so people are really
concerned, especially
with kids, getting
not permanently,
but temporary blinded or burned.
There's also issues that you can
imagine how easy that would be.
Hola.
TA: So I have a really quick
question for all of you.
Anyone wearing shoes with laces?
Can you please stand up?
And the rest of you just look
around and get a good look
at who has laces
and who doesn't.
Get this one clipped on here.
OK, thank you, guys.
You can sit down.
So I hate to break
it to you like this,
but I can see a lot of the
way you tied your laces.
And a lot of you just use the
simple bunny ears kind of knot
you learned when you were five
or six, which is great when
you learned it and worked well.
But honestly now, it's
kind of a dumb not to use.
I know you've been using
it your whole life,
but I can stand up
here and tell you
that because I'm a graduate
student here in Mechanical
Engineering, which
if you haven't heard
is probably the best
Mechanical Engineering
Department in the world.
So you know I've learned
all about design,
and good designs
and bad designs.
And these bunny ear knots
are pretty bad designs.
And if you want, we could
sit here and analyze
the stresses in them, and where
are the equilibrium points,
and why does it stay tied, and
why does it always come untied.
But the summary of all of
that is just it's a bad knot.
And you guys should
learn a new one.
But thankfully,
I'm here, and I'm
going to go through and teach
you how to tie a better knot.
So I'm going to kind of
step out of that character,
and ask you just
real quickly to share
thoughts or feelings of that
experience, and what I said
or what I did that
made you think or feel
the way you are now.
AUDIENCE: I don't actually care.
TA: OK, that works.
Other, anyone else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I
don't have my shoes tied.
AUDIENCE: You pointed out the
people who are doing it wrong,
which might make
them feel bad, but I
don't think I actually feel
too bad about the way they
tie their shoes.
TA: Good.
AUDIENCE: How have you been?
TA: Doing well.
So any other thoughts
about how I came across?
I obviously have
this idea that I
want to get you to learn how
to tie your shoes differently.
Do you think that was
the best approach?
AUDIENCE: So it was good
because you're really confident,
and so it was easy
to listen to you.
And your argument in the
flow of your conversation
was really easy to follow.
But I also think you
were overconfident,
because it was a simple topic.
And in fact, as you [? write, ?]
the MIT thing, I think for us,
it's good, because we're
all at MIT, of course.
But I don't know how it would
go over with other people.
So you think-- I
don't know, it seemed
like you thought you
were better than us.
TA: Like arrogant.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
TA: Yeah.
I was trying to be.
Right.
I mean, I also assumed
there's a problem.
I assume that you're not
happy with the way you're
tying your shoes, and there's
just this other, better way.
I mean, like you said,
I ostracized someone who
tied their shoes differently.
I didn't introduce
myself at all.
I just kind of barged
in here, and said, hey,
let me tell you about this.
Just the personal connection is
a pretty important thing when
you're working with people.
Also, I didn't really ask
any information from you
other than, could
you stand up if you
have shoes that tie with laces.
There was no other
exchange of information.
And so if I'm coming
in here and I'm
trying to help you with
what I assume is a problem,
it's good to interact and
get some kind of information
from you guys.
And also, I kind
of imposed my value
of keeping shoes tied
for a long time over what
might be a value of
ease to tie your shoe
or ease to untie your
shoe, or just familiarity,
or the way the knot looks.
You like the way
it looks, so you're
going to tie the bunny
ears over some other knot.
So I kind of just
assumed all these things,
and just put them on
you, and said, hey,
here's a better way of doing it.
So I wanted to use it
as a simple illustration
of some circumstances
you might find yourself
in going to Nicaragua
soon, when you're
working with people
there on the projects
that you've been working
on so far, where you're
going into an entirely
different culture,
working in communities
where you really don't
know how everything works.
And it'd be really
easy to come across
in these same kinds of ways.
So I wanted to just take
a minute, if we can,
to divide up into the teams--
you guys have been
working in teams--
and just talk about how you
might approach a situation
where you show up
to a community,
you have a community
partner, and you
have the project that you've
been working on all term.
And how would you go about
approaching the situation where
you just show up?
You get out of the van, or you
get off the back of the truck,
and you show up--
what do you do?
How do you approach the
leaders that you interact with,
or just the people there?
And so I remember last year,
we had about four teams or so.
AUDIENCE: This
year there's three.
TA: OK, so three teams.
That actually works perfectly.
And right before
we do this, I'll
introduce myself a little more.
I'm Steve Ray.
I know of some of you.
I'm a PhD student in
Mechanical Engineering here,
and helped out with
D-Lab: Energy last year.
But in order to
graduate, I needed
to spend a little more
time on my dissertation
this year, so I couldn't
help out more than this.
But that's it.
I went to Nicaragua last
year and it was a great time.
So you guys should be pumped.
You leave Friday or Saturday?
AUDIENCE: Sunday.
TA: Sunday, OK, cool.
So let's just break up and then
we can quickly talk about it.
And the three of us will just
help facilitate and help you
guys think about how
you could approach
this in a positive way.
AMY BANZAERT: I
just want to mention
that the shoe tying, I think,
is very comparable to cooking.
So you guys have been tying your
shoes since kindergarten-ish.
And most people have
been in the kitchen
since before they could walk,
and cooking from seven or eight
years old.
And so coming in and saying
you're cooking wrong,
which is somewhat what
some of us are saying--
hopefully not the [INAUDIBLE].
But fundamentally
suggesting changes
is comparable that
it sounds ludicrous
and what are you talking
about on the same level.
TA: And sometimes,
if there's something
that's relatively new,
you might not even
be aware of the problems with it
because you've just been doing
it the same way the whole time.
So if you observe
something and you
ask them, do you any
problems with it,
so things you can improve,
they say, not really.
It works pretty well.
And if you see things that
you think could be improved,
you could ask
them, well, what do
you think about decreasing
the time for this to work,
by making this change?
Or something like that, where it
might not be totally apparent,
but you can still ask
them how they would do it.
But starting with
what they see is huge.
AMY BANZAERT: And then I think--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: --really proud
of their solar cookers.
[INAUDIBLE] and so
treading carefully there,
respecting what they've
accomplished while providing
positive ideas for changes.
Thanks.
All right, so I know that was
kind of bizarre and weird,
but there's something
like communities,
just walking in while they're
going about their daily lives,
and getting
completely interrupted
so that you can talk to them.
And so just thinking about how
awkward and weird that felt,
and therefore, what
you can do that
wasn't like what Steve did--
because he was definitely
doing worst-case scenario--
in order to minimize
that awkwardness and weirdness.
So back to solar cookers--
so we were talking
about the concentrator.
It can be so hot
as to be dangerous,
especially for kids,
but really for everyone.
You can see that is
a big wind catcher,
so they can blow
over pretty easily.
That's actually an issue
with the Grupo Phoenix
solar cookers, too, because
this panel is so big
that it catches in the wind.
And then there's also a risk of
when you're stirring, spilling
food onto the reflector, and
then damaging the reflector
and how well it works.
So there's some real
drawbacks from the parabolic.
From the greenhouse,
it's a lower temperature.
And so you can really
only cook certain things.
But there's no
burning happening,
and you really don't need to
pay much attention to it, apart
from adjusting the
angle to the sun.
And then the combo
has some of the pros
and some of the
cons of the others.
So we talked about the
benefits are pretty--
oh, and the other thing here
is you really can't stir this.
Because as soon
as you open it up,
you're losing all
your heat, and you
have to start all over again.
So it's a challenging device.
AUDIENCE: What's
the box made out of?
AMY BANZAERT: So boxes are
made out of almost anything.
I've seen plastic, I've
seen wood, I've seen metal.
So some of the challenges that
people can be frustrated about
in addition-- so one is that
you have to cook outdoors.
And so in cultures where
cooking indoors is standard,
cooking outdoors poses
a lot of challenges.
So one is just the
need for privacy.
Another is just risks of theft,
of either your food and/or
your cooker.
And it's also,
for people who are
used to cooking around a fire,
it's a little less social,
or can be.
And so that can be a
flip side of frustration.
The super affordable
ones, like this one
is made out of cardboard.
And so they don't last very
long because termites tend
to eat them or other insects.
But they're very inexpensive.
And then they use
a plastic bag just
as your cover for
your greenhouse--
and again, very inexpensive,
but pretty short life.
And so then you have, with all
these things breaking down,
you have a supply chain issue.
You need to make
sure that people
are able to get replacements
and able to afford replacements.
The size, oftentimes--
I gave you a hard time,
Carter, about the size thing.
But it's true that
actually, a lot of the times
they're relatively small
for how much they can cook.
And so you can't always cook
for all of your family members.
That's frustrating.
There was an
interesting case study
where solar cookers
were brought to Kakuma,
which is a Kenyan refugee camp
for refugees from the Sudan.
And the Solar
Cookers International
gave away a bunch of cookers,
and there was actually
this cooker right here.
And so people are getting
their solar cookers for free.
And cooking was a huge
issue in these refugee camps
because women were having
to leave the camp in order
to get firewood.
And when they were, they
were regularly raped.
And so they needed
an alternative
pretty severely because there
was no safe option for cooking.
And they also were spending
over 50% of their income
on firewood, if they
were buying it--
so really outrageous.
And in the end, what they found
is that less than 20% of people
ended up using the solar
cookers more than one or two
days per week.
So that's a pretty
low rate of usage
for something when you're
facing really severe costs,
either to your bodily well-being
or your income, that severe.
So I think that speaks to the
challenges of solar cooker
adoption-- that people
don't love to use them.
AUDIENCE: Was that just because
they were not used to it,
or were there any major
kind of design flaws
that made them useless?
AMY BANZAERT: Well, so people
really don't like them.
These cookers work, but
all of these real issues.
Like you can only cook
for lunch, basically.
You can't cook for breakfast.
You can't cook for dinner.
You can only cook certain
types of foods, et cetera,
et cetera-- make them a
really of limited value.
So on the flip side at
Kakuma is that there
were a bunch of single
men there who were
separated from their families.
So normally in the Sudan,
if you're a single guy,
your mom cooks for you.
And it's not normal
for men to cook at all.
So either your wife or your
mom is cooking for you.
And so these single men were
separated from their mom,
so they didn't have
anyone to cook with.
And it was really
socially inappropriate
for them to cook with wood.
And so they were
actually the adopters who
use the solar cookers because
it was appropriate for them
to use these, because
they're really not
considered stoves the
way a firewood stove
would be considered a stove.
So that was the
success story, was
that when you needed a
radically different option,
it was relatively well adopted.
And the other aspect
is that in this camp,
there was a food scarcity,
also, which is unsurprising.
And so asking
people to experiment
with how they cook
when they don't
know if they have enough food
is a huge request of people.
And so I think that's
part of the reason
for the lack of adoption
was that I'm not
willing to try this wacky stove
because what if I ruin my food?
That means I don't eat
today and I don't know
when I'll be eating very much.
So that was the summary
of solar cookers.
There are any questions
on solar cookers?
I'm sorry, I dropped that over
the charcoal lecture or stove
lecture.
That would have been
the time to do it.
I don't know how it got lost.
OK, so now we're finally going
to talk about the trip a bit,
reverting back to what
Steve was talking about.
This lecture's a little
bouncing around intentionally so
that Steve could interrupt us.
So the trip goals
are, number one,
to have some well-identified,
well-understood,
and well-documented
projects, ideally highly
relevant to D-Lab: Energy.
However, if you find some that
are not at all energy projects,
but seem like
interesting projects,
we can often take these
projects and feed them
into D-Lab Design or
other D-Lab classes.
So if you learn
about some others,
feel free to document them.
It's really helpful to
D-Lab as a community
to have those extra projects.
And then we've talked about
a few projects for you guys.
There may be others that
come up that are either ideal
for you to work
on this semester--
and that's fine to change
course like that-- and/or
for future generations of D-Lab
energy students to work on.
So please document any
projects you come across.
And I will be getting
you, on Friday,
the sheet of how to
document so that you
have a good sense of what
information you need to gather.
But hopefully, we're
also getting that today.
Second is to really understand
the communities you're
working in so you can do
a good job of designing
with and for them.
What are their needs?
What are their finances?
What is their health, their
education, culture, government?
Both less critically, though
some somewhat critically in
terms of understanding
when grids arrive,
the formal government, also
like the informal community
government that
exists, and along
those lines, formal, informal
leaders, lifestyles, work, et
cetera.
And then doing the charcoal
trainings/creative capacity
building as appropriate.
So I want to talk a little
bit about creative capacity
building, which is a term that
Amy Smith coined for the way
that she hopes that all
D-Lab groups can work.
So I want to talk about what she
did at a refugee camp in Uganda
as an example.
So this is a relief camp
for refugees in Uganda.
It looks kind of picturesque,
but each one of those huts
is about 10 or 12
feet in diameter
and houses 20 people, generally.
And they've been living
there for 20 to 30 years.
So there's plenty of
people who have grown up
in this refugee camp.
Their choice is to be there
or to be completely unsafe
if they're not in the refugee
camp, either getting killed
or getting enlisted
into the army.
And because they're
in a camp, there's
really no natural resources
or ability to do work.
So there's a real
culture of dependency.
Things are finally safe enough
that this group of people is
getting-- and it's
about 100,000 people--
group of people is getting
ready to get repatriated back
to their original homes.
But people have basically
lived there their whole lives.
And so there's this culture
of dependency-- how are we
going to adjust back to home?
They're used to a very
centralized life in camp,
and adjusting back.
And especially the burden on the
women going back is very high.
Because all of a
sudden, they now
have to be figuring out
how to cook all the food,
get all the water, get
all the wood, et cetera.
And there's been very
little capacity building
in this camp up to now.
So what Amy did when she was
invited there was initially
do a technology
demonstration with
a classic D-Lab technology,
which is corn shellers.
And if you're curious about
them, they're on the back shelf
back there, so you
can check them out.
But basically,
the corn sheller--
people generally
shell corn by hand.
It's really labor intensive
and relatively painful
to do because the corn is
dry, and it's really hard
to get off.
And so D-Lab identified this
injection-molded corn sheller,
something that can work in a
lot of communities really well,
but it's really hard to
injection mold at the community
level.
It requires really high pressure
and plastic, neither of which
are available.
And so D-Lab developed two ways
of making that corn sheller,
either by welding or
by bending sheet metal,
that are really easy to make
basically anywhere, and allow
people to shell their own corn
very quickly, very affordably.
And people really loved it.
So they're really excited.
And so this is Kofi,
who traveled with Amy,
and another staff member.
They taught them how to make
their own corn shellers,
and people are really pumped.
And so this is both
just a tech transfer,
like doing a charcoal
demonstration.
I'm teaching you how to
make these corn shellers,
and hopefully, you can start
making them for yourselves
and using them.
Awesome.
But also to start inspiring
conversation about,
what else do you need?
And how could those needs
be addressed together?
And so one of the projects
that was discussed
was grinding, so
grinding their corn.
This is a traditional
grinding stone.
You can imagine how hard
it is to use this stone
to successfully grind dried
corn, how labor-intensive it
is.
And people found it--
or actually, not
corn, excuse me.
They grind sesame
and groundnuts,
which are peanuts, in it.
And again, it's very
labor intensive.
So that was the
issue posed, was how
do we grind our sesame
and peanuts more easily?
And so first they looked at
what the commercial method
is in that area is a
commercial grinder, which
requires diesel and is
totally unaffordable
for this community.
So they said, all right,
that's not going to work.
So let's design our own.
And so in a day, they
found a meat grinder,
and put together this really
basic, crappy prototype.
And partly it was crappy
because they had a day,
and partly it was
crappy intentionally
because they built this
with community partners.
Amy and Kofi really
took the lead
but working very closely with
the local builders, as well
as the local people.
And so people got
a really good sense
of how one could develop
this project really fast,
without the fancy MIT education
that Amy brings to the table.
But just they got
their head around,
oh, this is how I could do
this, and got really excited.
And they also saw how
relatively crappy this was,
and how there need
to be improvements.
And so they started
saying things
like, "When I build
mine, I'm going
to do this," which is a really
good indicator that they're now
feeling empowered
to build their own,
rather than when you come
back and build me another one,
it's going to look like this.
And that's the goal,
is when I build mine
rather than when you come
back and build me mine.
So people got really excited
and just tried it out.
And it was a great outcome.
So this experience helped
Amy solidify her thinking
about creative capacity
building, which
is we're not there
just for tech transfer,
we're not there just to identify
problems and then come back
to MIT and fix them, but
working with people side
by side through all areas
of the design process
to help them develop their
own solutions to problems
and work together with them.
And the nature of
a D-Lab trip, going
for a week in Spring
Break, is we can't fully
achieve all of this.
But at least if we have this
in mind, we can achieve as much
of it as possible.
Some of the amazing things
that happened on this trip
is that the translator
they were working with
told them that they were
the first foreigners
that this camp had ever
seen who actually did work.
Because most people
who come to do
relief work come
with clipboards,
and do a lot of interviews,
and ask a lot of questions.
This is not to attack
all relief work.
There's a lot of great
work that goes on.
But there's also a lot of
clipboard question asking.
And there's a need for that.
But actually having
people come and do work,
and work side by side,
is pretty valuable.
So for an example, here's Kofi
chopping wood for making fires,
because that's what
needed to be done.
So he helped out doing it.
And that's the kind
of thing that you
might start to do when you're
in your community next week.
However, you don't see a
picture of Amy chopping wood,
but you do see a picture
of Amy helping sweep up
after the demonstration.
And why is that?
Well, it's totally culturally
inappropriate for Amy
to chop wood, just as it would
be inappropriate for Kofi
to help sweep up.
And so while it's great to
break down gender barriers,
at some level, you also
need to be respectful.
And so Amy will
happily chop firewood
when given the opportunity, but
if it's totally inappropriate,
she won't, and vice versa.
So it's a balancing act
about helping people,
but also being respectful
of what's appropriate.
So it can be very
easy, in communities,
to let people just help you.
People will be really kind,
and gracious, and serve you.
And it's really important to
make sure that you're acting
as a community member
working, rather than someone
who's a visitor or guest--
even though you are--
only being helped.
The general rule of thumb
that Amy likes to say
is, "People are people."
So if you would help someone
out here doing something,
you should do it
there, and vice versa.
If you'd be really
uncomfortable helping x here,
then you don't need to
force yourself to be
super uncomfortable there.
Some of the advantages of doing
this sort of participatory work
are it's efficient.
And that's a deceptive
thing to say it's efficient,
because it takes
a really long time
and can be really frustrating.
However, if you're delivering
a product that no one actually
needs or is excited
about, then there's
a real loss of efficiency
there by not working with them
in the first place.
And similarly, it can be
effective to really work
with people and get something
that's really valuable.
It can help transition people
to a level of self-reliance
they didn't have previously
and help your projects
and the work become sustainable.
Some of the disadvantages
are it's slow.
It takes a long time.
It requires a lot of human
and material resources,
potentially.
There's a lot of
unpredictability,
as most teams have
already experienced,
and if you haven't,
you will experience.
And you have to be
able to just roll
with that unpredictability,
rather than getting
super frustrated by it.
I mean, you will get
super frustrated by it,
but not letting that frustration
be the dominant experience.
And then finally,
managing expectations,
both of not getting your
community partners thinking
that you're going to do
something magical that isn't
actually within your
power, or vice versa,
you yourself thinking you're
going to be doing something
amazing that's actually
not reasonable to expect
in the time and with
the resources you have.
So the typical design process
is trying to go from a problem
to a solution.
And you generally go through
generating ideas, evaluating
them, designing in more detail,
actually building, testing,
and evaluation.
It's not actually this
linear, of course.
But that's the general idea.
And so traditionally, you
would involve communities just
at the end.
And that's obviously not
ideal, for all the reasons
we've talked about.
And so then hopefully you
involve them in the beginning.
And the idea of
co-creation is that you're
involving your community
throughout all stages.
And so one thing to talk
about when you are there is,
I'm not going to be here
for the next few weeks
while I'm doing all these steps.
How can I stay
connected with you?
What's the best way to
be in contact with you,
so that you can
involve your community
partners as much as possible.
Are there any questions
about all that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] we have
Lindsay to be with the people
there.
AMY BANZAERT: So everyone--
so Lindsay is both really
useful as a go-between,
but she also
can't answer all the questions
that you are going to have.
Because Lindsay is one of the
organizers of Grupo Phoenix.
And so Lindsay may
be the person you
need to use to get the
answers from the women
you're working with,
but you can't just
rely on Lindsay, reasonably.
But she may be the best
way to get information.
So speaking of
information, I want
to talk a little bit about
what the barriers are
to getting good information,
and some of the methods.
So what makes getting
good information hard?
And what would you do
to get good information?
And by information, I mean
learning is this solar cooker
design actually a good idea?
How often do you cook with
the solar cooker, et cetera,
et cetera.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Language, yeah.
What else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
AMY BANZAERT: Whichever.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
iteration of [INAUDIBLE]
to make sure you do
those things [INAUDIBLE]..
that would be [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Well, I
think both, actually.
What else?
Cultural?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I think sometimes
you might run into some
people say one thing,
some say another.
So have an idea [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: I think time
[INAUDIBLE] that we're only
there for one week.
And we're all very
ambitious [INAUDIBLE]
want to get [INAUDIBLE].
And maybe we'll want to
bypass small, little things,
and then they make
a big difference--
like introducing
ourselves and making
that establishment
of personal contact
that this guy didn't have.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
Yeah, you can get much
better information
from people if you actually
spend the time to do
the introductions.
And thankfully for
you guys, you're
not in a community where it's
traditional to spend an hour
doing the introductions.
And how is your family,
and this and that.
In Nicaragua, at
least in these areas,
people are used to doing
things a little more quickly.
But doing the Steve Ray
approach-- not his approach,
but what he did--
barging right in,
and be, like, oh,
let me see your shoelaces--
is probably not the best.
Spending the time to introduce
yourself and get to know people
a little bit is
definitely going to help.
OK, so--
AUDIENCE: Gender.
AMY BANZAERT: Gender, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I wonder how
very much of a man or woman
kind of thing.
AMY BANZAERT: It
depends who you talk to,
but I would say it's not
as extreme as other places.
AUDIENCE: Is age
going to be a problem?
Are they going to have
trouble respecting people that
are younger than them?
AMY BANZAERT: I don't know.
It could be.
I didn't encounter
it as a big issue,
but it's always a possibility.
So some of the issues I have
encountered myself are--
yes, the language, and sometimes
you deal with the translator,
whether it's
someone on your team
or someone in your community
organization is helping.
Educational backgrounds
are different.
Cultural backgrounds
People tell you what
you want to hear,
what they think
as opposed to what you
actually want to hear.
And you may be easily
talking to the wrong person.
So to get into those
a little more--
language, obviously,
is challenging.
And when you use a
translator, there's
often times where you ask
a question that takes you
two minutes to say,
and the translator
asks a one-second question.
And then the person responds
by talking for three minutes,
and the translator says, "Yes."
And that can be
really frustrating.
And at the same time,
you're completely
beholden to your translator.
So if you take them
outside and yell at them--
I mean, I don't think
that's going to happen.
But if you took a really
pissed-off approach to this,
the effect would be even worse
response from your translator.
Educational
backgrounds-- so what
I mean by that is
that most of us
are pretty used to talking
in Watts, in Joules,
in inches, whatever, in units,
and just with a math sense.
And if you haven't
had a math education,
you may have a really
intuitive understanding
of all those concepts,
but you don't actually
have the same language.
So it's not a Spanish
versus English barrier,
it's an educational
language barrier.
And so it's beholden
on you when you say,
how long is that, expecting
3 inches, and someone
answers some other
analogy, figuring out
how to translate that
rather than saying,
well, is that 6
inches or 8 inches?
Because that's not going to give
you very useful information.
AUDIENCE: And they do
centimeters [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: I saw both.
AUDIENCE: Really?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
But a lot of it is without
standard units, too.
A lot of people just aren't used
to units and units of measure,
like what you're used to.
Cultural background,
of course, and then
telling you what
you want to hear.
It's really common
if you say, so
what do you think of
my design, they'll be,
like, oh, it's great.
Yeah, we'll totally use that.
Awesome.
Love it.
Yeah, it's good.
And unless you both ask
your question more carefully
and keep probing, you'll
never hear beyond that.
And it's really easy when
you're proud of something to be,
like, well they
said they love it.
Awesome.
And so working through
that is important.
And then also talking
to the wrong person--
so it can be really easy to ask
all your questions of Lindsay,
for example, as the
community organizer.
And she speaks
English, et cetera.
And she'll give you some
really good insights,
but if you just talk
to her, you won't
get the right information.
Or you can interview someone
about cooking habits,
and then if you forget to ask,
how often do you cook, and find
out actually they
aren't the cook,
but they'll answer it because
you're asking these questions--
if you don't ask
the right questions,
you're just never going to
get the right information.
And there's classic
examples of that
in terms of talking to the
male leaders in the community
and never talking to the
women in the community.
I think that'll be less of an
issue for most of you guys,
given who you're working with.
But it's something
to keep in mind.
So I got to this, and
you got to it, too--
so some of the methods to manage
this are asking the same person
the same question in many
different ways, multiple times,
as well as asking
different people the same
question multiple times,
anticipating that you're
going to get some variation.
Another thing you can
do is ask some questions
that you kind of already know
the answer to, if you do,
so that you can get an indicator
of how reliable this person is
in terms of giving you
useful information.
Because some people
are much more on the
telling you what they think you
want to hear side than others.
And there's some
probing questions
you might be able
to develop that
can help you get around that.
Demonstrating an
openness to criticism--
and that generally does
not mean saying, oh, you
won't offend me, tell me
whatever you want, but can mean
something like, I've talked to
some people who've criticized
or have said they don't like
this idea because of this.
Is that something that you
think might be a problem, too?
Why or why not?
And just repeatedly attacking
yourself so that you actually
get some criticisms from them.
Because as great
as you all are, I'm
sure there's going to be
some flaws in every approach.
And so getting to
those flaws helps
you get to a really
great product faster.
Repeating answers back
is a classic method
for making sure that there's
understanding on both sides.
Encouraging questions,
very explicitly saying
what questions do you have
for me, what can I tell you,
is pretty important.
Verifying expertise--
so as I mentioned
with the wrong person, if you
talk to someone about cooking,
actually making
sure that they cook
would be a good thing to do.
And then finally, dealing
with the translator,
spending some time
beforehand talking
about what your goals are,
what your preferences are.
Because translators
have choices in terms
of do they give you the
detailed response or do
they just give you the yes?
And if you're on a time crunch,
you may just want the yes,
but if you have the
time, you probably
want the detailed answer
with the subtleties,
even if it's more
painful to translate.
So one of the
challenges when you're
working on engineering projects
is getting to the core problem.
And that ties in to the
project specifications.
So someone will say,
I need a new stove,
instead of I need to not
have such a smoky environment
in my kitchen.
And you need to make
sure you're asking
the questions to get to "smoky
environment," not "new stove."
It would be really easy to
specify that brand-new stove
without getting the
right question answered,
which is the smoky environment.
So partly, it's making sure that
you're not letting them design
for you, which everyone does.
It's really hard
to describe what
you need in terms
of specifications,
as you probably just found
out, or saw in that 2-level 9
lecture I linked to
when trying to describe
a lemon or a piece of fruit
as a product specification,
rather than, "I need a lemon."
That's much harder.
But this is actually
the information
you need to make a good design
so that you're not going down
the path of a design
that may not actually
match the real needs,
because it's easier
to think in products
than in specifications.
So getting to the core problem--
some ways you can do that, in
addition to just being patient
when people talk about what
they want in terms of a product
and then you translating
back into the specifications,
is, "Tell me what would happen
when you use this new thing.
Tell me a story about
what that would be like."
And have them walk
you through what life
is like with this new option.
When you're trying
to find out more
about what the specifications
are, rather than saying,
how big should it be, saying,
well, how big is too big?
Is 10 feet-- is
this big too big?
Is this big too big?
And again, I just
said, "10 feet,"
and that's probably not
what you want to say.
You want to use your
hands to gesture
or use some other
things to compare.
Because 10 feet, even
for us, is a little hard
to imagine exactly
how big 10 feet is.
And for someone
who hasn't grown up
using rulers and tape measures,
et cetera, it's harder.
And so I put "big" and
"small" in parentheses
because it could be
like how hot, how cold,
how whatever-- all sorts
of different things.
Challenge their requests.
So if they say, oh, no, it can't
be bigger than this, say, well,
what would happen
if it was this big?
Why would that be a bad thing?
So that you really understand
what they're getting at.
And then getting feedback
on your own ideas,
including ones that
are problematic,
so showing them a design
that you know some issues
and getting feedback
on it, trying
to get them comfortable with
criticizing so that you can--
and then also listening to
the way they're criticizing.
What they're catching
maybe opens up
some information for you.
And then finally, as you're
engaged in these questions
and conversations, taking time
mentally to review what you
know and do a mental design
process of writing down
the specifications, and being,
like, OK, I know these things.
What else don't I know?
So that you make sure to
get to all the questions
you need to ask.
And it's kind of hard
and takes practice,
but you guys will do great.
So now, I'm going to save
that till Friday because we're
running out of time.
So I just wanted to go over--
or maybe I'll get back
to it if I have time--
the packing list and
trip advice, which is all
posted on Stellar.
But in case you haven't
had a chance to read it,
I know they're kind of long.
So some people were
earlier asking me,
do I need to buy a new x?
Probably not.
There might be one or two
things you want to buy,
but generally, the
goal of D-Lab is not
to make yourself broke going to
travel to a developing country.
So very little needs
to be bought new.
And pack lightly, which
is in direct contradiction
to the two-page packing
list that I provided you.
But basically, that
two-page packing list
is the list of all things
that someone at D-Lab
really likes bringing.
And so some people really
value certain things,
other people value other things.
You have to know yourself
what are the objects that
are going to be
important for you to have
and what are the ones
that you can skip.
So there's just a couple
that I have on that packing
list that are in blue.
I didn't even put underwear
in blue, just the ones
like a flashlight that
if you don't have,
it's going to be really
hard for you to function.
So things like that
you have to have.
Everything else,
that's your call.
So if you don't have Teva's,
you don't have hiking boots,
you don't have whatever,
don't worry about it.
Don't go out and buy yourself
a $200 pair of hiking boots
that you'll never wear
again just for this trip.
That's not necessary.
So pack lightly.
With that being said, it can be
as cold as 50 degrees at night,
so you might want a light
fleece or something like that.
And then in the middle of the
day, it's wicked hot and humid.
Relatively conservative
dress-- again,
for a lot of these things
I'm asking you to be more
conservative than you may
see most people being--
not most, but many people
in Nicaragua being--
because again,
we're representing
MIT, and D-Lab, and yada, yada.
And so we want to be
respectful to the people who
are on the conservative side
in terms of dress, et cetera.
Toiletries-- so if you
have any medications
that you need to take, you
should take twice as many
as you need and keep them
in two separate places
so that if a bag gets stolen
or lost, you have your meds.
You definitely want to bring
toilet paper, or tissues,
or something like that you
can use for toilet paper,
because not all
places will have it.
You won't be offered
a towel, so if you
want to have a
towel for showering,
which will be bucket showers--
so taking a scoop of
water from a bucket
and pouring it on your head--
you should bring one.
But I would bring a small one
because they're pretty bulky.
You definitely want bug
repellent and sunscreen.
The sun is much
stronger, and you
will sunburn if you
don't wear sunscreen,
if you're fair skinned.
Flashlight, again, is key.
Having a photocopy of your
passport, bringing a notebook,
like I mentioned.
And then nothing of value--
so you shouldn't be
wearing your Brass Rats.
You could skip earrings or
wear really small, subtle ones.
Cameras, like a small, junky
point-and-shoot is fine,
but a DSLR is not ideal.
Again, you'll see some people
in Nicaragua with DSLRs,
but they're making the
choice for themselves
about having that,
and therefore,
bringing the potential
crime associated with having
a fancy device there.
And it's not fair
for you to make
that call for your entire
team on that camera.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What kind of
risk are we talking about?
[INAUDIBLE] waterproof and
shockproof, or is it theft?
AMY BANZAERT: Theft.
AUDIENCE: So even if we--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMY BANZAERT: So do you have
a waterproof, shockproof DSLR?
AUDIENCE: What's DSLR?
AMY BANZAERT: Like the big--
AUDIENCE: No, not the big one.
AMY BANZAERT: So a point
and shoot, totally fine.
Yeah, yeah, so that's
what I'm saying.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMY BANZAERT: Like a camera
that's this size is fine.
A camera that's that size,
not fine, is what I'm saying.
Ones that have the
switch-outable lenses
is a DSLR, fancy, nice camera.
That's what I'm asking
you not to take.
Point and shoot you
should totally take.
And then laptops,
your team probably
shouldn't bring any laptops.
If you need to, you should bring
one, but definitely not more
than that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you recommend
bringing more than one memory
card for a camera?
AMY BANZAERT: Yes.
So I recommend bringing as much
memory and battery charging
capability as you can,
both because you'll
have limited access
to electricity
for battery charging,
and then you may
be taking a lot of pictures.
And you may not have a laptop
and be able to download them
until you get home.
I'm not sure why that's--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Cellphones.
AMY BANZAERT: So
the thing that's
complicated-- so
every trip leader will
have a cellphone with them.
So for emergencies, there's a
way to call the States or a way
to call within your country,
or whatever you need.
I can't see why you'd
need a cellphone.
It might be nice to have during
your layovers or whatever,
so you might want to
bring it for that reason.
But if it's anything
at all nice--
and I'm concluding my
junky phone as nice--
but anything that looks
fancier than like flip phones
that people had 10
years ago should never
be visible in Nicaragua.
So if you're going
to bring it, pack it
in the bottom of your bag
as soon as you get to Miami,
and leave it there rather
than taking it out.
So again, you'll
see a few people
with iPhones in Nicaragua,
but they're taking a risk.
And you shouldn't have yours out
and about while you're there.
But the one thing
is that most of you
are leaving super,
super early on Sunday.
So you do want to have your
cell phone out that morning,
from that middle of the night,
just to make sure you're awake.
I don't know, at 3:00 AM, I
feel like most you probably
won't even sleep right.
I don't go to sleep if
I have to leave at 3:00.
But yeah, we want to
make sure you get there.
So one other thing
you want to bring
is gifts for your
community partners.
And some criteria for what
makes a good gift is one,
that it's not extravagantly
over-the-top expensive
because it can set up a--
the disparity between wealth
can be more significant
and make people
feel uncomfortable.
Also, you may well
be on a budget,
and I don't want you to go broke
buying gifts for your family.
Other things are, will
they actually use it?
Will this just become
some piece of trash
that adds trash to the
community in places
where they're relatively
pristine or not?
But we don't want to be adding
to the trash load, et cetera.
So D-Lab has a
few things that we
buy that are branded
as D-Lab objects,
that you can buy from D-Lab.
So gifts are not something
that D-Lab pays for.
It's something that you pay
for as a team or an individual
because they're from you.
And so it's up to you
to decide how much,
but I think something
is appropriate.
So sports bottles are $5.
These hats, maybe $6 or $8.
Hats, I think, are
a pretty good gift
because people can wear them.
And they like them, and a lot
of people wear baseball caps.
But don't bring
them Red Sox caps
because most of
them like Yankees.
And those are the only two
teams that are basically
known, from what I saw.
We also have these
little flashlights.
Oh, I think the battery is
blocked so I can't turn it on.
But yeah, the challenge
with these flashlights
is it means the battery
has to be replaced
and things like that.
So it's a mixed bag,
how valuable it is.
But they're fun.
There's little drawstring
bags, which people like.
I often bring chocolate to
share it with my family.
I'll bring a couple of hats to
bring for someone like Lindsay
or someone who's helping you
a lot, and then for the family
just bring chocolate that
you can share with them.
Trader Joe's sells pretty
good, pretty cheap chocolate
that travels pretty well.
Some chocolate melts really
easily and that's not ideal for
given how hot it is.
But some of the nicer chocolate
comes in three packs for $2.
And just sharing that with
your family, it means something
you can share with
all the members.
And it's nice, and it's
from your home country.
Chocolate and Nicaragua,
in my opinion,
is far inferior to chocolate in
the States and a lot of people
I know agree.
And so something like
that is also appropriate.
So are there any
questions on gifts?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] any
of these [INAUDIBLE] gifts?
AMY BANZAERT: So I'm trying
to leave a little time
at the end of this class
so that your team can
make a list of all the
things you need from D-Lab.
And these gift things
are among them.
In terms of money
that you might need,
you should bring
your Charlie card,
because you'll probably
be coming back on the T
if not going there.
There's an entry visa cost
to get into Nicaragua of $10,
and if you just have
a $10 bill on you,
it's nice to not have to
deal with the customs agent
making change.
If you're bringing cash--
you may want some cash for food
that's not already prepaid,
which you guys will reimburse
us for after the trip,
or for gifts for yourself
to bring home, for yourself
or your family members
at the airport,
if not while you're traveling.
There'll be opportunities
to do a little shopping.
So you shouldn't bring anything
bigger than a $20 bill.
And smaller bills
are nicer generally,
because it's hard for
people to make change.
But the bill should be
in decent condition.
If they're really ratty,
people won't take them.
And then if you
expect to be needing
to use your bank,
or credit card,
or debit card either for
general just getting money out
of the ATM or for
an emergency, you
should call them to warn
them that you're traveling,
so that if you do
need it, you can.
Because usually, they'll
block any charges
unless you told
them ahead of time.
Some tips-- so you should assume
that drinking water is unsafe,
which means that any vegetables
or fruits that aren't cooked
are also unsafe.
Because they were probably
washed in that unsafe drinking
water.
So each trip leader
will have a water filter
that you guys can use to
filter your own water, which
means you really do want
to bring a water bottle so
that you can have clean
water in that water bottle.
But this is definitely something
to be cautious on so you
stay healthy for the trip.
Because it's such a short
trip that if you get sick
for a few days,
that's half your trip.
Nothing expensive, at least
in sight or brought, so
like a Brass Rat, or nice
jewelry, or watch, or whatever,
leave here.
If you need to bring that
cellphone so you have it
while you're in the States
while you're traveling,
just keep it hidden in your
bag so that it's not being
brought attention to at all.
You should always be
traveling in groups, ideally,
but especially at night.
There's going to be some
cases where that'll be tricky.
But do your best to be
as safe as possible.
As I mentioned,
flexibility and patience
are really great assets to have.
So just go in not
expecting to be
as efficient or effective
as you necessarily hoped.
And expect that things are going
to change at the last minute.
And that'll help
make the trip more
fun rather than frustrating.
And then managing expectations
with the community partners--
it's really easy for
community partners
to be, like, when
are you coming back.
And you're so pumped, you're
having such a great time,
and you're, like, I'll
be back this summer,
not thinking about actually, I
have an internship at whoever,
and I'm not going to
be back this summer.
I may never be back.
And so you don't want
to make any promises
that you can't keep.
That's really important because
that can ruin our relationship
with our community partners.
So just a reminder, a few of
you still owe me at least some
of these things.
And so please get them
to me today or tell me
why you can't, and what
you're going to do,
if you haven't already.
And so for the
remainder of the class,
I need to do micro interviews
with everyone who's traveling.
It's just a D-Lab
thing that we do.
We just talk one on
one really briefly.
You may want to revise
your plan a little bit
based on feedback from
the presentations.
You probably want to
talk in your group
about how much checked luggage
you're having versus carry on,
who's carrying what for
any bulky items you have.
Things that you might
need from D-Lab,
I need you to tell me by
the end of class today.
So you might need tools.
You might need cameras.
We have some that we can lend,
mosquito nets, hammocks, other.
It'd be nice if at least
a few people have cameras
so that you can get
different angles of shots
when you're all taking
pictures together.
And also, if one dies, you're
not unable to take pictures.
Because pictures are really
important for the projects.
And then anything else
that you might need.
So are there any
questions about all that?
OK, cool.